President Trump plans to temporarily
suspend immigration into the u.s. to
protect American jobs states are quickly
burning through their funds to pay out
unemployment claims some are asking for
help international stocks drop after
some US crude oil futures plunged below
zero for the first time hi I'm Jason
Bellini with the latest reporting on the
coronavirus crisis from The Wall Street
Journal President Trump tweeted that
because of the invisible enemy that is
the corona virus he plans to sign an
executive order to temporarily stop
immigration to the US while providing
few other details he said the goal is to
protect American jobs
administration officials said the order
wouldn't make substantial changes to
current policy because nearly every form
of immigration has been paused including
processing visas the order is likely to
face legal challenges new york has asked
the federal government for a four
billion dollar loan with no interest to
help ensure the state continues to pay
unemployment benefits States usually tap
their unemployment trust fund balances
to pay regular benefits but nearly half
of states have logs double-digit
percentage declines in their balance
since the end of February before the
pandemic shut down the economy and
triggered a record 22 million people
filing for unemployment Massachusetts
has used up about half of its available
funds and California's balance dropped
nearly 40 percent it's at 1.9 billion
dollars in mid-april no state has run
out of money but officials are already
planning for the possibility global
stocks dropped today after some oil
prices fell below zero for the first
time on Monday may oil contracts briefly
dropped below minus-30 $7 per barrel
meaning that some investors could be
paid money to receive oil some storage
facilities are overwhelmed as demand has
fallen drastically with lock downs in
many countries we report that Saudi
Arabia and other OPEC members are now
looking to possibly cut oil production
sooner than the May date they had agreed
upon with you
in Russia